This is the kill test.
To see what kind of lethal
damage your blade will do,
we're going to
deliver some slashes
on this wild boar carcass.
Joe, Casey, you're up first.
You ready?
- Oh, yeah.
[heavy metal music playing]
All right, Joe, Casey,
off the bat, it is light.
You got the weight perfect.
On the draw cut
right here, you can
see that it lacerated easily.
The cut here in the spine, you
can see all the nice pieces
of bacon that we're
going to make later
on with this particular carcass.
You blade, it will kill.
Good job, gentlemen.
Thank you.
- Mark, Jessica, you ready?
- Definitely
Absolutely.
[heavy metal music playing]
All right, Mark, Jessica,
now, your blade is wider,
but the balance it's light.
In this particular slice,
almost cut in half,
but definitely, on the
final cut, blighted easily.
Your blade, it's curvaceous
and sexy, and it will kill.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, I'm going
to take each of your swords
and deliver one Herculean strike
on this piece of sheet metal
to see how it
affects your blade.
Joe, Casey, you're up.
You ready?
- Oh, yeah.
We love to test blades.
It's killing us right now
to not run over to Ben
and grab the sword
from his hand.
[music playing]
This is a beautifully
light sword.
It's very well-balanced.
I like the string wrap / it's
easy to keep a good grip on it.
The edge took a
little bit of dulling.
There's a piece
of the sheet metal
almost welded onto your
blade from the impact.
But it's still very well done.
Thank you.
Mark, Jessica,
you guys are up?
You ready?
Indeed.
JESSICA: Ben is about to
do something to this blade
that should never be done.
Slamming into a steel plate.
Good Lord, why
would you do that?
[music playing]
BEN: Mark, Jessica, this is
a beautiful sword to wield.
It's so comfortable,
it's so well-balanced.
The steel did a little
number on your sword, though,
and there's a chip right there.
But for such a light and
fast weapon, as both of these
are actually, it's amazing that
they got away this unscathed.
Very well done.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
To test the edge
of your blade and see
if it's retained that
edge, I'll be cutting
through these water tubes.
Joe, Casey, are you guys ready?
JOE: Oh, yeah.
CASEY: Let's go to work.
[dramatic music playing]
Joe, Casey, your sword
has a great feel to it.
I like the shape of the grip.
There's that section
where that edge is rolled,
and that's where
the cut started.
And you can see that first
tube kind of crushed.
Then it starts to cut as
I get up into the sharper
section up in here.
By then, everything had
pushed over and kind
of crushed that last tube.
It's a beautiful piece.
Well done.
- Thanks
- Thanks.
All right, Mark,
Jessica, you ready?
- Indeed.
- Yeah.
OK.
[dramatic music playing]
So, Mark, Jessica,
you maintained
a bit more of an edge here.
You can see that cut
travels through there.
They're clean across
the tops, didn't
blow out any of the tubes,
didn't crush any of them.
Anyway, a beautifully
made piece.
It's definitely a cutter.
Nicely done.
- Thank you.
Bladesmiths, your Chinese
dao's have been tested,
and the judges have evaluated
the finer details of your work,
and they've made
their final decision.
The "Forge in Fire"
champions are--
Mark and Jessica.
Congratulations, you are the
"Forged in Fire" champions.
Joe and Casey, your weapon
did not make the cut.
David Baker's going
to tell you why.
Joe, Casey, you brought
us back a Chinese dao that I
personally would
be proud to own,
and it was a real
pleasure using it.
But in our kill test,
on the boar carcass
and on the sharpness
test on the water tubes,
your weapon just didn't perform
as well as your competitor.
And for that simple reason,
we got to let you go.